[Music]
i believe in soul mates strongly agree
strongly disagree answer in the comments
below and suggest a prompt on our
kickstarter
i've dealt with like homophobic people
just like anyone else and there's a lot
i can handle but what i can't handle is
seeing you hurt
[Music]
we were pressured into getting married
three two one go
so we're mormon like lds and there's a
lot of pressure in our church to get
married especially at our church school
that we went to everyone gets married
really fast we got married after like
five months because we wanted to and you
know we loved each other but i feel like
it definitely like there are like some
more like societal pressures in that
aspect so that's why i don't like
strongly disagree but i mostly disagree
because i don't feel like we were yeah i
feel like we were kind of not
necessarily pressured to get married but
more pressured to date for marriage but
then once we met each other and told our
families they're like hey maybe you
should slow down so you're more so
pressured not to get married but yeah i
would say zero percent pressure like
when i first saw this woman i was like
oh i gotta get to know you girl and i
honestly we have both been through
broken homes before we both come from
divorced families and uh
a big passion we have is having strong a
strong marriage and so i was just i've
never been more confident about anything
in my life than amber jay there was real
pressure it was all pressure on me like
i gotta hope she's feeling the same way
because i'm feeling you
and we actually
dated for less than a year as well
but when you know you know right
i have some hot takes submitted by our
audience and so i'll read off the prompt
and you'll agree or disagree with the
prompts
women do more work in marriages
[Music]
i feel like no one should be doing more
work than the other person in the
marriage personally
i feel like in order for a marriage to
work you have to come at it equally that
might be just an idealistic view but i
don't know
yeah i feel like
like as a general statement most of the
women i know and including the women who
have raised me had a job they also took
care of the kids like most of the time
most of the household chores also fell
on like you know on the woman and i do
just see that more often than not that
women take on two jobs literally
i have considered divorce
you know we learned this in a marriage
class where there's a rhino and a
hedgehog in every relationship marriage
and so charlie's very much the rhino
he's like let's tackle this now we need
to talk now and for me i'm a hedgehog i
need to withdraw and so i think in those
moments i don't know i think i'm more
here it's just like will you know when
you're in the heat of the moment you
know what i mean yeah no i definitely
know that our communication styles are
totally different we didn't communicate
well at first i know kenzie comes from a
divorced family and then saw their
family just fight me a lot i came from a
family where my parents had a
disagreement they fought with passive
aggressive comments and closed doors so
having disagreements having those uh
uncomfortable and hard conversations
just wasn't easy for me at all and so
divorce sounds a heck of a lot easier
than
pushing through it which luckily we did
we're doing great we're happy now but
there definitely was a time where yeah
it seems easier to just drop everything
and move on instead of trying to grow
i am happy with how often we have sex
[Music]
there's a hedgehog there's a rhino and
then there's a rabbit
i feel like i'm the rabbit in this
marriage
and
my expectations and like my
like sex drive is my libido's very high
but it's always been that high so we've
i came in honest it was on the table
i feel like sometimes you know work and
life get in the way of that
responsibilities but i think
yeah
we're trying to find a middle you know
we're both here it'd be you know i think
if we had split then there would be like
evidence that we're not talking about it
uh but i think this like this is not a
surprise to me i don't think it's a
surprise to you that we're like we're
both here because it's it's something we
talked about i think yeah i think it's
like something we're working through and
it's just like
when you get married you get into like
this routine you get into like just
working and going you know and then at
the end of the day you're just like
spent we're both like really too
ambitious people and
i think like sometimes it's the
detriment of the household sometimes on
both ends not just you but like yeah
i want children
three
two
one
go
if we could we would have a baby
yesterday but because we're we're same
sex there's a lot of costs that go
behind making a baby so we bought a
house last year and
that was huge for us now kids are on the
table and that's another
you know forty thousand dollars that
you're looking at per kid and if we want
two that's a house and then some 80 000.
so and as women our clock is ticking the
older we get the less time we have to
make it happen so for us it's a little
different so we actually have like
infertility struggles a lot we've had
three miscarriages we actually just had
one recently and so it's like the topic
of kids is like super sensitive to us
because like we actually like our
miscarriage happened like last week and
it was like really like hard because we
were so excited we told our families and
we were like so excited to like announce
to everyone at christmas
and
sorry
it like breaks my heart because like i
know like it's bringing us closer
together but it's like one of the
hardest things we've had to go through
together
because it's like i know tyler's gonna
be an amazing dad
but like i feel bad and some like i feel
bad cause i've told him before i'm like
it's fine if you like want to go marry
someone else and have kids because i
know i can't provide that
yeah now it's been really hard to deal
with just because like
it's not the most
like i guess accepting topic to talk
about i know a lot of people feel very
awkward whenever that conversation does
come up like my parents have tried to
help us out but
don't really know how like it kind of
makes me want to like be over there
sometimes where i'm just like no it's
not worth it like don't like the
heartache and the financial like
struggles it's just not worth it
but at the end of the day it's like i
know it's worth it i know this is where
i want to be
[Music]
i don't like my partner's family
three
two
one go
this is challenging
speak your truth i know you know um i
think there are there are certain
members of your family that i absolutely
adore
it's okay
and i think there was a time and place
where i really wanted to love
your mom
and there's a time and place where
we just can't
i have very thick skin i knew what i was
like signing up for um i've dealt with
like homophobic people
just like anyone else and there's a lot
i can handle
but what i can't handle is seeing you
hurt
and that's the hardest part
because like you're so amazing and she's
gonna miss out on so much
i mean i totally understand why you're
standing there i wish you could stand
here with me but i was raised in a super
homophobic family and
unfortunately
you can't really choose who you're born
into so i totally understand your
frustration because i carry that
frustration and i've carried that
throughout my whole life
i i'm shocked you're there
no i i'm not um i think
i think this is a silver lining right
like when i married you i gained a
family and even though
i might disagree with certain points of
view in your family overall your family
has been
loving from the moment i stepped into
your life and i'm really appreciative of
that because i feel like i put a lot of
pressure on my friends because they are
my family
but when i met you i feel like your
family filled in that hole
i think that's like the beautiful thing
about marriage is that like you guys you
get to set like a new precedent like you
get to set a new like standard for your
family and like that's what's so
beautiful about it like you don't have
to take on you know what your family
brought or what your family gave to you
guys can make something new
there are things my partner doesn't know
about me three
two
one go
but for me it's like i've had like a lot
of like hardships in my life that's like
it takes time to unlock you know what i
mean and like talk about and i feel like
if i was like trauma dump like you need
therapy too i mean you did trauma dump
on me like before we met though like
we met on a dating app and her first
messages to me before we were going on a
date was like by the way i went through
this this this this this within the last
like 12 months or so i trauma dumped on
you on our first date so i was like okay
if she's still here
at the end of the day then obviously i
have to marry you and like here we are
and i think if there's anything i don't
know it's the new things that we explore
together not necessarily super focused
on the past like what you ate on your
third birthday like probably don't know
that but like you know let's go explore
something new because like this is
you're my future
[Music]
i'm with my soul mate three
two
one
go
this is an interesting question uh
i think
i have like a
disagreement with the the term soulmate
uh
me being over here is not me saying that
you're not the person that i'm supposed
to be with it's just me saying that like
i have so many opportunities to do so
many different things and go down
different roads in my life and i chose
this one
and then every day i'm going to have to
continue to choose this one
yeah i didn't know that's what soul mate
meant to you
yeah first time hearing you explain it
that way i mean for me like soul mate is
just someone
you just know you want in your life and
when you and me got together i was like
like there was just no fear there was no
um
like there was just nothing else like i
had no hesitation going back to the
beginning we talked about when you know
you know
and so i feel like we did not meet by
accident it was definitely a divine
orchestrated event for us to cross paths
since i grew up in la and charlie grew
up in detroit michigan and so it was for
a reason
good marriages don't just happen right
it definitely does take work intentional
time
but i wouldn't want to do it with anyone
else so
jay is a lesbian
you've known you've loved women from
like very very beginning i identify as
bisexual
before i met you i never wanted to get
married when i was with women maybe i
wanted men when i was with men i wanted
women it just felt like there was always
something missing and then i met you
and everything
changed in my soul in my body and in my
choices like
and so i used to not believe in
soulmates because i felt like how can
out of whatever billion people in this
world you just match with one in like
the universal lines it's just too much
work for the universe like i feel sorry
for it but when it works out there's
just no other explanation that so much
inside of me can change by meeting one
person
that is a wrap
[Music]